welcome you're listening to the dollop
we're on the all things comedy Network
and we are an American history podcast
now each week I Juke owner Labradoodle
daddy-o
a new low has been found you know cuz
you just spit on your mic about that
dynamic Labradoodle daddy hammock ah
liar inner oh my god Dave Anthony we
destroyed from American history to his
friend he careth Reynolds who has no
idea what the topic is gonna be about
Labradoodle daddy it's my maple it's my
girl go with labra daddy how dare you
dare you how dare you there's an
official term that we use in the circle
oh you did a spit take I got on the back
of my jacket I got a labradoodle daddy
jacket now right around my Harley oh my
god Labradoodle dad a ball that yeah you
got a girl no they called it quote his
jam-packed champ I'm the [ __ ] hippo
guy they look as Garrity but it's good
and this is not gonna come particularly
okay now hit him with the puppy you both
resent sick arguments
Oh Oh
I couldn't hear it we couldn't hear it
songs over should wear headphones every
now and then we had them taken away cuz
I trust take them away
justice curb here Frank is Frank Frank's
one of the best in the biz goddammit um
let me ask you something okay Gareth
yeah let's say you're a guy and you're
having some issues you having a lot of
issues right now okay is this the same
guy as the other guy waste some time no
it's a totally different guy new guy
yeah so say you you double tariffs and
aluminum and steel and you and you'd put
tariffs on soybeans and farmers are
totally screwed and all the business are
going out of business hypothetical
person yeah and so you had this you see
you had a woman named Amoroso that you
had working for you just a random now
I'm gonna have to that's like that's
like a version of layers that's super
specific and and say she came out her
said that you're a racist and you used
the n-word all the time I think if
that's the case that you should you
should try squarespace talk space [ __ ]
let's try to talk space yeah
Squarespace wouldn't help you at all
with that no I didn't use the n-word
calm no you should definitely go to talk
space it's an online therapy company so
that makes more sense than using
Squarespace with your shirt a webpage
company yeah yeah um cuz talk space lets
you message a licensed therapist from
anywhere at any time where a Squarespace
you just put up a web page
yeah right no talk space makes my way
more sane for this guy yeah I don't know
if this guide is hypothetical gotta make
a website uh I probably wouldn't he
would probably yell things at it and
then cry and eat a hamburger all you
need for talk space is a computer an
internet connection or talk space mobile
app and then you're ready to get go you
don't you know therapy isn't about
getting into your childhood
all stuff you can talk about everyday
stuff to help you with maneuver the
everyday nightmare that you've created
of being racist specific again specific
like if someone said when you were
hosting Celebrity Apprentice quote my
certainty certainty is about the N word
tape and it's frequent uses of that word
were the top of a high mountain of truly
appalling things I had experienced with
him during the last two years in
particular she if that was said about
you that was like that was out yeah you
would reach out to talk to someone about
and ask someone about that what you
should how you should handle that
there's no no commutes right no you're
not going to an office anywhere you just
come so I'm gonna come here to the White
House toilet that's right having a
therapist simply provides you a
designated person for you to talk to who
is trained to listen and help you make
positive changes the talks based
platform has over 2,000 licensed
therapists who are experienced in the
dressing life challenges we all face to
match with a perfect therapist for a
fraction of the price of traditional
therapy go to talk space.com slash
dollop and use code table to get forty
five dollars off your first month and
show your support for this talk show
it's a talk show it's not a talk show
what is it it's a podcast for this
podcast that's dollop and talk space.com
slash Dollaz sometimes I don't know did
you lose part of your memory this is a
podcast not a talk show it's not a talk
show are you saying this could be a talk
show or a podcast this is a podcast no
I'm interviewing you it you're not
interviewing me we've never talked about
you down for the first time we're
talking about swim shorts okay Frank
Frank also we here at the dollop are
sponsored by third love third love is a
brassiere company bra yeah you probably
call it a bra and you're in your line of
work yeah my line of work yeah we call
it broad my line of work carpenter yeah
I wife my wife purchased a third bra
when when they were like hey what do you
guys think about their bras I was like
I'll tell you what I think about third
bra if there's love or third bra sorry
Wow Jesus I'll tell you what I think
about third love right I haven't been
drinking I'm just tired
but it's going on today it's gonna long
let's sleep in the Sun it was hot I was
out a lot today yeah yeah my kid he's
been using the he should not be using
third love he's about he's about 240
pounds okay
sure okay I know so my wife ordered one
she's like this is nice I know what it
means she enjoys the bra she says it's a
nice fit holds yeah I don't know it dad
some point of some point crosses over
and a weird yeah just I mean I should
like to say is that yeah yes thanks for
adding got padding she likes the shirt I
asked her a question she's like I don't
want to talk about this and that's fair
but you're asking from a different
standpoint you're allowed to know you
know be by Kate tell me about it tell me
walk me through it talking talk me
through your third love bra is it your
third love yeah which would be me you
get out of pen and pad of paper and you
sort of lay down in your tummy and you
have your legs kicked up and you're like
dish girl if the third love bra is is
actually the third Lebanon I first it's
versus probably up my kid and then it's
me and then it's probably the broaden
than the dog right so she's the
Labradoodle mommy that's right yeah sad
little situation you know third love
helps you identify your breast size and
shape and find styles to fit your body
so that's good for you know that I had a
friend who recently it was like I've
been wearing the wrong bra I've heard
women say that before they died but no
thanks I'm 38 I just found out yeah yeah
that happens and as a guy you like I go
through that it's super comfortable
tagless no itching straps won't slip
ultra soft smooth fabrics lightweight
super thin memory foam cups that's what
we talked about earlier thank you I'm a
third love guarantees a perfect fit
returns and exchanges are free and easy
okay third love knows there's a perfect
bra for everyone so right now they're
offering our listeners 15% off your
first order go to third love comm slash
dollop now to find your perfect fitting
bra and get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love comm slash top 15% off
to tah boom
well David I'm gonna plug a couple
stand-up dates
19th which is this coming Sunday I will
be at stand-up live in Huntsville
Alabama at 7:00 p.m.
headlining a little baby and that's the
medical term and then September 7th and
8th they'll be at cap city comedy and
Austin headlining four shows there
that's Friday the 7th of September and
the 8th of September and now you can go
to gear Thrones calm
I used talked space to build a website
yeah we have a gig coming up this
weekend that is not sold out Minneapolis
were there Fri that's all that Saturday
is not so die up there's not that many
tickets left though so you might want to
jump on it we're gonna be in Cleveland
on the 14th will be Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh sold out sorry hello there we
have Australia shows coming up right now
we have one on sale it's Las Vegas left
to 9 28:18
at September at the Highline Ballroom in
New York City jump on those what you can
cuz those are going fast then we're
gonna go down real quick
you got Australia will be in Perth
Brisbane Adelaide Byron Bay Canberra
Sydney Melbourne the Hobart so get on
those and then go just go to dollop
dollop podcast calm yeah hit the tour
tour page it's all there hit the page
also Houston just happened and we had a
second show in Boston all right so there
you go everybody yeah don't scream with
me yeah yeah you know why you're mad
right now but somehow you're mad and I
don't understand what happened and I'm
sorry we took too long with that and
know a lot you guys are mad about that
I'm sorry my voice isn't always right I
apologize for that the Salt Lake City
there wasn't the audio is enough to get
one up yeah yeah Thank You Emma
Emma was sent us a file because the guy
never recorded the show right well and I
think one of the things that people
don't know about podcasts like live
podcast is you if you don't record them
you can't release them that's right it
has to be a podcast yeah you have to
have that rip that is correct there must
be a podcast yes exactly
so he just recorded hissing which is not
great he probably he probably I assume
he put in the wrong inputs that would be
my people are asking why we don't bring
a sound guy with us because these clubs
have some guys professional sound guys
and they're supposed to be competent and
what we would do is we would hire one
and then he would come out and then we
would go oh you're not good either
so that's just a thing and what it would
do to us I mean we have a good rhythm
going down the road we don't want to
have a third wheel no Starbucks or sound
guy less I'm gonna bring his Frank over
here a berry no Frank yeah bring old
Frankie it may as well bring a pillow
case of nails oh what's up Ricky don't
boy gay is there anything else I think
that's it July 20th 1887 okay William
Floyd Collins was born in a burn a Logan
County Kentucky all right yeah yeah he
had five brothers and two sisters much
of Kentucky is what is known as karst
topography karst yeah now you're uh you
wanted to documentaries about the stuff
they were going to the cave systems you
ever learn about caves and watch stuff
about caves sure okay so karst the karst
KR st is a it's soluble rocks it's it's
limestone it's it's things like that
right and and it's in a wet area so what
happens is underground get a lot of
caves you know the sinkholes give a lot
of underground streams yeah so
Kentucky's got a lot of caves right okay
so if Floyd started exploring Kentucky's
caves all by himself when he was six
okay that's and again I'm sure there's
someone listening is going hey that's a
shocking thing to hear
hey guys relax at six your it's time to
get down some of the yeah these caves go
have a look in a black cavernous hole
along it's sick I mean you know a lot of
people are like it at six years old
should I let my son play in the front
yard alone yeah back then you let him go
into a cave and not a lot of people know
that home alone
actually based on whole alone that's the
story of a six-year-old who gets lost in
a cave and then thwarts two gold-digging
dweller dwellers yeah when he was 10 he
dropped out of school and with a live
Stone bandits his plan at that point was
to just go into caves and look for
Native American relics that were in
there so they it's quite an ambitious
job yeah yeah yeah so he would find
arrowheads and stuff like that and then
taking about sound of tourists great
yeah sure working for a living Ted ten
that's we could find a job his job
yeah normal by 12 he had a he had
memorized a nearby cave that was huge
and then he started checking out other
unknown caves around the area okay so
he's the cave boy though the caves
aren't the caves are [ __ ] huge yeah
these caves are sometimes they're miles
yeah yeah they're massive and yeah and
especially these ones here all right so
this this 12 year old is just going
caving yeah okay
so he's finding moccasins tomahawks
beads sometimes the bodies of other
explorers who didn't work out for
interesting in 1910 a New York geologist
paid him to work as a guide in local
caves while he was you know mapping them
or whatever for two years okay during
this time the geologist taught Floyd the
basics of geology right he's becoming a
learned man sure I learned it I learn
and learn and learn 'red know fly became
convinced all caves in the area were
connected okay so he thinks every single
cave in Kentucky is connected together
this end with him finding out chopped oh
yeah okay he was soon squeezing through
cracks and that other explorers were
absolutely terrified to go my boy
there's no way I could fit in a god no
he became known as Kentucky's best
cavers so he gets a rep you mean so he
gets an agent yeah he got so this is
actually a shot yeah there's that second
you shot him that a magazine came and
took because he's getting so popular the
people like what are you doing down
there okay and there he's getting some
bones and whatnot they're in the cave
okay
people started telling stories of Floyd
going into caves and coming out miles
away popping his head out in some random
owners Hey
okay Dover right just like a little
whack-a-mole right yeah so he's like
Bugs Bunny at the beginning of the car -
it's like I should have gone left at
pickup see but okay you know I mean yeah
that's so that's him so okay so he's a
real cave boy he's a kid boy in 1917
Floyd discovered an amazing underground
cavern with vertical walls a smooth
ceiling and tons of white orange and
brown formations he thought it would
make his family rich he named it Crystal
Cave and started promoting it to
tourists okay and it would be a common
look at the cave right but it's so
remarkable because it's just a Solars
okay yeah I mean just the way it was
huge was huge on the inside but also all
the colors yeah okay no one came though
interesting because there's other caves
around okay three caves no there Charlie
everyone charges together got their cave
they charge people to get in oh it's a
racket okay people would go you take it
you take a family trip down to the cave
area sure check out cave yeah go in
Griswold it down a cave that's right
right it could only be reached by taking
a very rough wagon trail so he bought a
taxi to drive tourists out but it turns
out he was a terrible driver
he once actually drove into the
broadside of a barn okay wow that's uh
no that's bad yeah that's all right he's
not great doesn't mean you should be
able to see that coming
I think go barn yeah yep other other
cave so other came owners don't want him
to become successful right right because
they're competing cave businesses sure
so they would tell tourists his cave was
closed or blocked the road with boulders
and wagon not even a cave no came out
there that's above land look like a cave
man okay okay it's trees and stuff yeah
then five goons demanded Floyd hand over
the lease to his cave hey we don't want
to make it too difficult on you but I'll
give us the the lease and the deed to
your case okay
I think there's no give me the paperwork
that says that you own that cave ah
first of all I don't have it okay yeah
we wouldn't want you to fall backwards
onto some of those stalagtites I just
you know that yes are you sure there's
the ones that come up or do you think
they're the ones that go down I could
never remember well done well let me
think what did the teacher say what she
said was the leg tight hold on touched
so I think your point is
well taken I would not push you back
under those stalagmites
yeah because Mike might hit you in the
ass
now you're actually wrong I was right
the first time yeah look we're gonna
kill you unless you give me the leash
yeah that's fair so they beat the living
[ __ ] at him they beat him so bloody its
brother to come out and chase them off
with his shotgun I project Homer he's
got a brother Homer just to make sure
right just a normal Helmer
so Floyd keeps on going he's still he's
not intimidated by the cave beating
that's right
that's for it okay he's not intimidated
that that picture looks like when
someone estimates what someone will look
like when they're older and they've gone
missing yeah for sure okay do you always
wears hat sideways yeah he'd say he
looks like Steve Coogan if he was stung
by a wasp on half his face on half of
him he wanted to find a cave that would
blow away the competition and save his
family from all their debt problems so
when he was 37 he found a narrow
passageway and he spent his whole life
is cave he's he just thinks that he can
find the right cave perfect cave then
the family's out of debt no problems
everyone's gonna live happy it's it's
like it's strike it rich they go for
gold or creating a start-up in Silicon
Valley yeah yeah stupid [ __ ] that
people do right okay dog you can make a
dog app it tells you where to put on
this is where I got an idea for a dog
app and when your dog needs to eat it
tells you it goes beep let's see when
your dog how about this I've got an app
for you it's called
dog then your dog tells you when it's
hungry oh and the Dinan app oh yeah I
don't know how we make money off that
yes right that's my point
okay yeah look thanks for coming you're
welcome
so he's 37 he finds his narrow
passageway which I will show you I think
this has been cleared out a little bit
that's what it looks like today okay I
think was much much smaller I think at
this point there's nothing there but a
tiny hole ya know it's hard to tell he
spent 12 hours a day clearing away
gravel and stone God more like weeks
four weeks oh he's just go in this
little hole he's clearing out because he
knows he's gonna hit a cave at some
point a big
on Monday January 30th 1925 he walked
through the melting snow and headed into
the cave it was warm for the winter then
she is now a manhole sighs he had a
kerosene lamp slung over shoulder five
yards down he lowers himself into a four
foot drop and then he crawled on his
belly under jagged rocks after fifty
feet squeezed through a tight area by
exhaling and pushing his body forward
with his toes that was just a horrifying
sight from Aaron Aaron does not like
cave
he crawls for a while and then he had to
wiggle through another tight area and
then he was in a pit he went down 10
feet into another hole and he went
through and came out on a Ledge that was
above a 60 foot room okay
they found a room all right this is this
is the day he discovers this room yeah
so he's just finished okay he just found
a [ __ ] giant 60 foot right okay so he
finds a big room
then his Lander starts to die okay so he
turns back but then he knocks over his
lantern
no no so now it's pitch-black oh boy he
doesn't panic because he's been in a
situation before sure he's [ __ ] Floyd
Collins yeah he's dealt with light
sounds not Homer yeah he knows how to
handle lights out cave that's first time
goes back through the bottom of the
10-foot pit and lunges but his foot was
against so he gets in this area and he's
gonna push himself forward right okay
but he puts his foot against a rock and
that rock is not solid so he pushes and
ton of gravel falls around his legs and
his waist
oh no so he can't move so he's buried
they're not doing too well over there
this is this is what my parent's worst
nightmare okay so he is now he's
basically like quicksand at himself in
the cave yeah he's he like all this
rubble falls on him so he can't oh I
should here's a picture him I didn't
show this this is like an action shot
that they took of him like a
photographer came I like let's get you
one a cave so that's okay it looks like
it hello
so so this is how he is stuck
it's not that great but so that's him be
around yeah he's gotta be laying down
there okay wow that stuff is so he's
really he's basically the only thing
that's out is like his chest up other
than that he's just covered right okay
and he can't move because there's a big
rock on his leg right well I have his
left leg okay again another another
upsetting noise from Aaron so whenever
he moves or struggles more rocks fall he
clawed at the walls until his
fingernails were bloody ah finally
exhausted he passed out and when he woke
he just started screaming that's the
best way to wake yeah yeah yeah just so
this is a pattern he sleeps he wakes he
screams he falls asleep he wakes he he
sleeps he wakes he screams he sleeps he
wakes he screams hours of this loses his
voice that's yet oh man what a good one
his arms go numb cuz his arms are buried
underneath him so wait when he was
leaving there once on top and ones on
the bottom that's how it is so one yeah
so one second underneath who once stuck
above him but he can't move either one
yeah so uh pain is shooting from his
ankle which is injured now the melting
snow water sweet water because of where
his face is water is dripping down
directly onto his face so he's just like
oh sweet yeah he's just video opening
his mouth and filling it like a birdbath
I mean the good good thing is water the
bad thing is that's Chinese water
torture like that yeah but not open your
mouth or not if you open your mouth you
okay for normally it's just a head
that's getting a good I mean and if you
think about it at that rate he could
probably get a full sip every two hours
if he's just cards right which is nice
yeah yeah
so now 25 hours go by Jesus picture
James Franco playing and now no one no
one up top has been worried until now
because they're used to Floyd going on
going I'm going spelunking
and then he'll he'll come out of the
cave somewhere and be like hey Jimmy can
I stay with you and they're like yeah
sleep in the barn or whatever so
there used to him being gone for long
time but then after after like 30 hours
I think it it was this they start to go
oh boy it's not around and they started
talking it Floyd sit your place last
night nope nope nope
and then the 17 old kid goes out looking
for Floyd and he finds the hole and he
he worms down into the cave but he
couldn't get anywhere close because he
could not do what Floyd he couldn't no
Floyd's the best Floyd's the best caber
in the area
that's what Floyd went through it looks
like I'm not a zat restaurant they give
you a kid that's the top so we went that
and he went all the way down across
backups Jesus that's a [ __ ] show so the
kid yells his name and Floyd yells back
come to me I'm hung up I'm hung up and
the kids I cannot do and the kid ran out
to get help so one by one men start
coming and they try to get in go each
one wants to be the hero go on the cave
and reach for but they can't get
anywhere [ __ ] close no no everyone's
like Jesus Christ hey so they would fail
they come out they'd be soaked in mud
saying they would never go down in that
hellish hole again so by mid-afternoon
Dunn's dozens of locals are gathered at
the hole when Floyd's 22 year old
brother Homer arrives
hey man should I shoot at some men are
outside the cave arguing I do a picture
okay so so Homer goes into the cave men
arguing outside he goes straight in he
just walks by everybody arguing trying
to figure what to do okay the cave
smells like cigarettes and alcohol from
all the guys who've got in before him so
those gentlemen while they're going down
there to save this man are also having a
drink the smoke also I might want to
drink before I went in the cave I think
about it or drink while I'm in the cave
yeah no for sure definitely get down
there all right I'm dead freaked out
going to have a whiskey at a Pall Mall
I don't know if it's whiskey there's
also moonshine territory oh Jesus yeah
so Homer get everybody in the 1800's was
like the beginning of a prelude SEC
commercial pounding like turkey legs and
just bath booze I don't I don't know I
don't know at what point this happen
but to get through others Hummer I don't
know which one he's I think he's this
one right here my guess is that one the
one that looks absolutely terrified I
used to blink but then I stopped so he
takes off he gets in the cable ways and
then to get through the skinny places he
takes off his pants shirt and shoes and
slithers through in his underwear
I'm coming brother naked it's gonna be
weird when I get there super weird
all right brother I'm scraped up and
hard and naked give me your hand
do you want some moonshine Italy you
Homer there we go
you ruined caving come on take your
clothes off we're gonna be naked heroes
take my clothes off get out of here I
look foolish if your clothes and I ain't
yeah well that ain't now that ain't
right at all flawed what's you're doing
right all right I'll tell you what I'm
gonna put on a glove then I'm gonna be
naked yes come on smell what you you I'm
drunk I've been trying to get you out of
here for a while I drink a lot of shine
I am blinked in years so when Homer gets
to the 10-foot pit right that's this
area he realized the horror of the
situation so he's there
Oh enough right if one went into the
chute headfirst
he'd have to work upside-down and to get
out he did he go hockey first and that's
20 feet before we turn around he has 20
feet up sure so if you go feet first
thank you for doing then you write so
you'd have to contort yourself into
almost impossible positions to get down
to reach him right so that's what Homer
did he went down feet first
and he calls for someone to bring down
bring down food and then someone else
comes in and and then Homer fled fed
Floyd by hand nine sausage sandwiches
and a pint of coffee poured the coffee
daughter's throat she's also flat so Wow
so he ate a lot he was hungry nine
sausage sandwiches imagine they weren't
that big huh maybe do one more
Jesus ploy do you have how long keep it
down there maybe pot of coffee two more
sugar some more men go down and
fail wait did I skip okay sorry homework
comes out tries to it they tries tries
to remove rocks from around Floyd he
can't they're just to about impact them
but he's feet first
yes he's feet first so he's a crouched
down just like between his legs were
dropping sausage business open my
picture but that's what you painted but
that's what's happening Jesus feet on
the each side of his head
it's basically called out house and it's
where I squat naked and drop food in
this hole you can actually online there
Floyd porn and that's what it is just
food into his brother's mouth now man
the cave look at that he loves me look
at him sausages going on mouth closed
bagel bats so he can't get him out and
and when he tries to pull rocks out more
falling it's just a [ __ ] strip show
so he decides to bail and and he goes
back up top cuz he's he's exhausted he's
well I will say having nine sausage
sandwiches is probably well I mean
there's the upside being like there's
now some something's going through your
body
the downside is it's you know probably
you're probably gonna have to go potty
soon yeah so Floyd comes out that's what
he looks like when he comes out what
they get it oh that's Floyd right no
that's Homer that's Floyd right there oh
sorry that's Homer oh that's Homer okay
yeah that guy looks like a beat-up clown
yeah he had a rough time down there cuz
it's brutal for these guys to do these
moves to get down and get back up it's a
[ __ ] haul unbelievable for these guys
for Floyd it was no no issue he came out
of hole hours later he's shivering
violently skin was dangling from his
fingers so he takes a break more men go
down fail they can't get near him nobody
could reach him home and went back down
at midnight for eight hours Homer hacked
at the rocks around Floyd with a crowbar
no luck he came up at sunrise his arms
and back ached his lungs burned there
were now tons of strange people up top
smelled like moonshine Floyd had been
trapped for 48 hours so they've just
turned it into sort of a music festival
everyone just sitting out there so they
might as well drink and stay warm and
whatnot right drink and stay warm yeah
that's what I would do so he he so it's
it's it's it's a [ __ ] mess and we're
on I mean we're what like three days and
now 48 hours he's been down there for 48
hours so they're so they're starting to
set stuff up and rush and try to rescue
him they're doing a real dig yeah
they're starting to dig and do different
things them started a real dig yet but
they're starting to like open trying to
open up the hole and open up spaces
inside sure at least create some sort of
shoot for the sausage sandwiches just
like I just got bad it's got bad really
fast new man had ideas the new man
arrived once said Floyd should untie his
shoes
smart smart so that guys understands the
situation and knows how to fix it guy
comes over with an idea a plan say hey
boys
ya know I just got here but I was
thinking as at my home heard about this
came down y'all tried untying his shoes
well problem is for his fix it unties
shoes his head and his torso and the
rocks are in the way so we can't get to
his feet but if you can got it right now
fella I got a you untie the shoes I'm
fella let me just jump in here mm-hmm
that's an impossibility unless we came
from the other side which we would not
know how to do all right now it's
nothing all right
it's not an answer to this just
wondering if they might be
double-knotted that's all he can't get
to them maybe cuz they're double not we
can't get today all right wanna go back
home boys please do remember the to
remember the shoot thing I talked about
blew out another said send a
contortionist down with a mallet and
chisel now y'all are sounded crazy I
heard about every crazy idea that's
imaginable another said use dynamite now
for the last time the way to fix this
problem is to blow Floyd up that's right
we want to blow the whole so no one can
get out or in now for the last time we
need the contortionist from Ocean's
eleven to get down there he's the only
one who can fit into that hole
someone said they should amputate the
foot and see if he can make it out
before he bled out okay so a real
concert
that kind of a tail race against time
yeah that guy wanted like a clock
situation happening say we cut him in
half and raise them separately how are
ask some teenagers to bring Floyd down
some blankets and food and drinks they
went in they couldn't make it anywhere
near down and they just stuffed all the
food drinks and blankets into cracks and
the cave and left he was real happy mr.
grown grown men did the same thing and
they all lied and said they hate giving
food to him oh [ __ ] so he's just like
plays Homer is the only one no feed him
that's right a reporter approached Homer
and Homer said quote if you want
information there's a hole right over
there you can doughnut go down and find
out yourself
now the reporter's name is Skeets
oh if there's any reporter that sounds
like he'll go down the hall it's one
name Skeets
Skeets Miller whoa so he's been down now
he's been down the hole for it's like 50
hours supporters named William B Mel are
known as Skeets he's 21 he put on
coveralls and headed in he's skinny
he's 117 pounds so he this reporter was
like all right yep he's never he's never
caved he's not a caver he's scared he
crawls in he squeezes all the way
through cuz he's so skinny
Florida Eyewitness News hello what's
your what's your favorite kind of food
have you tried to tie on your shoes
examine minds want to know
at the last tight spot Skeets called for
Floyd and heard a groan Oh sausage so
Skeets leads down the 10-foot pit and
landed on Floyd's head oh good that's
what he needed was a concussion 20-foot
funk ya know Skeets apologized this is
like The Goonies he goes back up and
carefully slid back down so he would not
be on top of Floyd's head Oh but Floyd
is completely incoherent at this point
why I don't know okay lazy ya Mesquite's
headed back out Floyd didn't have been
trapped for 73 hours
well I kicked his head real good he
all right he's hungry and I kicked his
head on he made some moaning it's not
good so he's hallucinating he's seeing
angels wrapped in white linens riding
blazing chariots I think that means
you're close yeah he smelled liver and
onions freshly froth the cow's milk and
chicken sandwiches so he's just smelling
an afterlife potluck he yeah he it's my
it's now Monday February 2nd uh I don't
want to live I gotta go eat potluck with
the Angels he went done on Friday
lieutenant Robert burden a 33 year old
Louisville firefighter arrived he was
confident and very arrogant he was also
super skinny in he went when he reached
Floyd he said quote you got a hell of a
problem here but I think we can get you
out with a rope ok I like that idea
voice it ok yeah let's do this bird and
then looked more sized up the whole area
and said quote we might have to pull
your foot off off off off off
take that foot off take the foot off
yeah well said that was another guy's
hope I pulled not take her off pull her
off pull the foot off yeah with the rope
right when we pulled the rope we're
thinking baby I'll come around all right
ok so have the foot torn off yeah I'm a
fireman ok yep right Floyd didn't care
he said quote pull my foot off get me
out Wow
he's tired of it yeah two hours sure
yeah burden may not have known Floyd had
lost his mind earlier that day I must
loosen a ting anyway he thought he got
approval he goes I don't know he tells
everyone Floyd it had agreed to the Rope
polling plan ok the crowd did not
approve every one of the locals are like
that that doesn't sound that sounds like
medieval like [ __ ] up he's like a
crazy Louisville man try taking his
shoes off take it untie the show shoes I
just say that I run away they dragged
out of the place uh so they said it
would break his foot or if it didn't
pull off like it would be a disaster so
a doctor in the crowd said the rope pull
would stretch Floyd's internal organs
like taffy so there's a lot of the
doctors good there's a lot of against
and the doctor understands what's going
on yeah he's like don't little gentleman
intestines aren't taffy
yeah so he's a weird one yeah he was
also like what we've pull apart well
being taffy for wait she has taffy and
says every man knows and as any man of
science knows we're all filled with
different came let me show you boys oh
god it's not taffy now if we're not
careful we might strike the now and
later and then skittles up everywhere
burton says look there's no other option
i've been down there all we can do is
pull him with a rope the locals had no
responses they had no ideas so everyone
agrees reluctantly okay let's pull him
out with a rope okay so 5:00 p.m. a body
harness was brought down put around him
Homer Skeets and Burton went in with a
hundred foot rope and when they got to
Floyd Homer gave him ham sandwiches
coffee and whiskey okay sure
that's great then Floyd said he didn't
actually want to have his foot pulled
off okay so now he's had some food and
he's like wait we doing yeah oh wait I
ever think I like my foot well we're not
as worried about the foot but the doctor
pointed out your taffy might get
everywhere so so now he's come to and
he's like let's not do this right so
Homer slipped him a sedative probably in
some food sure knock him out okay quote
to build up his vitality to stand the
shock if we did pull off his foot yeah
uh-huh
that's what it does it really heightens
the experience Homer tied the harness
around and tight put the harness around
tied the Rope skeets was crouched at the
top of the pit burden is further up in
the cave several other men helped near
the caves mouth and on homers count they
all sort of pulling okay and Floyd
scream like dammit okay so he's just in
horrid pain so it turns out he's lying
face-up right you know and a horizontal
horizontally faced up yeah he's laying
like is no well sort of his lower body
trapped and his back is kind of turned
into an L
his back okay so his but his spine is
sort of tilted you me ad okay yeah down
like it's it's like it's times like that
it's like angled okay so it's a lot
harder to pull them out so in other
words are they talking about
maybe maybe taking off the bottom half
right right right right so from the the
belly button below sort of yeah so I'm
gonna need to give another knockout ham
sandwich so that he just started
screaming don't do it don't do it don't
do it and ever we could hear all the way
through the cave which they've now
they've now named the Sam cave yeah so
Homer started pulling in the opposite
direction and as everyone doesn't he
starts pulling the other way sure back
towards everyone else and he had enough
strength to pull it from the other men's
hands okay Homer does like a feat of
strength thing Floyd does Homer oh it's
Homer doing it okay
so it's over didn't go well bad plan
they head back out to reevaluate they're
like we can't pull him he screams and
then I get torn in half right Jesus they
were all particular they're all pretty
freaked out by what had happened burden
the firemen fainted as he got near the
exit okay his idea in facts right the
crowd outside is getting larger it has
been eighty eight hours oh my god
then came Floyd's childhood friend
Johnny Gerald Johnny Gerald
when Johnny first heard that Floyd was
stuck in a cave he shrugged and kept on
chaperoning the local high school Boy
Scouts voice boy boys basketball team
that night I was having the best with
you he's not worried at all he'd
explored caves with Floyd all of his
childhood and if anyone could get out
flow he could get out but after two days
he started to worry and he headed for
the cave and when he arrived there
around 200 people mostly shit-faced
hardly any with caving experience and
johnny was really disgusted by the idea
of trying to pull Floyd out right he's a
basketball coach so this he's like run
the triangle offense I know if he's a
coach or he just like hangs out make
sure they don't get in trouble
sure deal because you know basketball
players yeah you know they like to do
their thing yeah for sure so so he so he
he goes down okay he's a he's he cannot
believe all the the bottles and the
clothes and the [ __ ] crammed and cracks
it's like a Six Flags a night now he's
like we could open a store down here
quote enough sandwiches in the cave to
feed the whole crowd there's a vendor
how you doing sir turkey legs that Floyd
was thrilled when he heard Johnnie was
coming down I mean imagine like communic
hey Floyd make the place look nice you
got a visitor - one of your old friends
is coming down close your eyes I thank
you quote let him down here he'll get me
out out of his mind
yeah anyone is coming 88 hours hey break
him out down he'll fix this but Johnny
was stocky could not fit down the
10-foot pit so he pulled rocks away
until he was able to slink down around
midnight then he started removing the
gravel around Floyd he spent the next
six hours trying to enlarge the area
Floyd's torso appeared and then his hips
and then his upper thigh sorry this
great plan was to dig the gravel out
from around him well hey but that's the
first thing you have to do before you do
anything else why is nobody else done
this that would be like the first thing
you would write I do
I think Johnny has a lot of caning
experience maybe he's just like get out
the rocks before you do where you rip
the man in half nobody else knows okay
so he's pulling out all the rocks so
he's done let's see his hips than his
upper thigh so he's all the way down to
his upper thigh and for the first time
Floyd could wiggle his right leg as
painful as that oh my god the atrophy
and then he could also move his arms in
his hands now he can finally eat this
enemy whoa yeah that's right
but Johnny was too big to reach past for
his knees but he moved about a half ton
of rock at that point Wow yeah that's
pretty [ __ ] amazing yeah
so before he goes up Floyd told him
quote not to let anyone come down here
down there but him and his party so he's
just like just usually your party nobody
else your boy Johnny greed thinking
Outsiders could cause a cave-in
so he's worried about people coming
the cave we don't know anything about
cave right when he got back to the
surface he was approached by a group of
professional Stonecutters okay they
don't find him doing that guys who work
on jewelry there's I don't know maybe
maybe they cut bigger stones but they
wanted to chisel the limestone above
Floyd's head and giant told him to get
the [ __ ] out yeah okay cut the part off
a buzzed head and then what happens well
the rock falls down on his head but then
you've got his feet yeah how we get them
out ideally so then we can finally take
his shoes off get him out of there so
the fireman lieutenant burden comes back
at 10 a.m. and he has great at it he
says they should try to pull him out
with a rope again yeah that's smart
that's good that was that was close last
time but I mean in a way he's looser
right like is it is it now time because
you guys I had a Eureka moment been
thinking all night long got a great idea
all right let's pull him out
all right great how do the same thing
put a rope around
we tried that plan he almost ripped it
yeah but this time will be different I'm
not so this time when he he said that
idea when everyone shouted [ __ ] you at
him and he and that was it okay so he
had a good run
yeah so now Floyd is blurb and
newspapers across the country this is
because Skeets had written a story right
Floyd have been trapped now for a
hundred and three hours oh my god
so Skeets goes back to the cave sure for
the follow-up I already did that Skeets
there's no excuse so she eats goes back
to the cave whoa hello skates he's not
[ __ ] killer they get some ladies I've
got Skeets with the deets at 11:00 so
the idea was to set up a chain of men
who would pass food equipment and rocks
up and down the passageway while
reinforcing it with boards okay so you
got guys moving rocks out at the same
time and taking more sleeping at the
side of the cave okay seriously building
a mine you're building a mine lightbulbs
be set throughout the cave well so so
they did that so now there's like an
orange glow throughout the cave that's
nice yeah Skeets would then go down and
try to remove rock
and gravel from around Floyd the hole
around Floyd's torso had now had five
inches of clearance okay so that's
pretty good that's great
Skeets could prop his legs past Floyd's
head and wiggle hip-deep in in this
weird position he would pop past Floyd's
knee he's probably hanging
rot on top of him right oh good feet
first
right okay to get in deep enough to then
dig I don't know how this works it's
almost like spelunking sixty-nining it's
now it's a sex cave okay so but he is
essentially he's going over him he's
over him he's on top of him he's laying
on him
he's digging past the knees able to
reach past the name so for two hours
Keats passed up buckets of dirt and
rocks with Floyd Floyd starts to talk
quote I believe I would go to heaven but
I can feel that I am to be taken out
alive and with both my feet four days
down here and no nearer to freedom that
I was the first day how will it end how
will I get out or I couldn't think of it
I have faced yet before it doesn't
frighten me but it is so long no God be
merciful I want you to tell everybody
outside that I love every one of them
and I'm happy because so many are trying
to help me tell them I'm not gonna give
up I'm gonna fight and be patient and
never forget them you go out now but
don't don't leave me too long I want you
with me know and I'll keep helping all I
can can to move some of this rock oh boy
oh boy
Skeets goes back out so Floyd's doing
well yeah yeah he's keeping it together
yeah he writes up he writes up what he
said in a story he writes up what
happened in this trip and so now Floyd
is a nationwide event of course front
page head of course it's bound to happen
yeah
Skeets also wrote about his own feelings
of fear so so normally at this time
reporters are not supposed to ever put
their feelings into something but Skeets
did write he didn't do the weird and
then they did this is he like put how
scare
and all that [ __ ] in there so everyone's
like reading and they're totally on edge
and into the story play houses around
the country would be interrupted during
the show to update audience I'm sorry
everybody we all know how Macbeth ends
so we're gonna take a quick timeout
Floyd has had his eighth sausage biscuit
and he believes that he saw the devil
all right as you are that's four so oh
boy yeah he was dapper before he went
down there in DC President Coolidge
followed the story closely Congress
stopped debates to find out what was
going on now hold on
I yield I yield to the newsboy in to the
news of the caveman go ahead newsboy
yell something well he's a fixing the
leaves Dale that was great sorry I
should to come in yeah here ah boy got
an offer of three hundred and fifty
dollars a week to star in a vaudeville
show it might be premature does things
now how's your tap-in floyd before we
put the deal together can you tap
assuming you leave with both feet i
could tap with my nose alright and what
about their monologues do you feel good
about memorization no wanna do already
and how do you feel about working with a
female maybe we do something a little
bit less key yeah you any like a foot no
right well great floyd will draw this up
and i think we're gonna love you
assuming you make it out of here alive
what assuming you lay it out here alive
we can't wait to put together a show for
vaudeville boy a real razzmatazz you'll
see remember that kid who fell down the
well lost his arm I'm the one who made
him a snare household name dead Tommy
that's right dead Tommy it was nothing
to tell me so I'm the one who suggests
that he bleed out so now Skeets got more
and more determined to save Floyd he
wrote quote I believe I can save him yet
I know it in his last story and he went
back down this time he planned to use a
jack to lift the stones off Floyd's foot
okay but the team couldn't find the
right size jack sure so Skeets used one
that was too small and he piled wood
blocks against the cave ceiling uh-huh
and grabbed the blocks with one hand
while wrenching the jack with the others
he basically made like a post right in a
way to hold on to okay reaches in with
the jack with the other and he would
loosen this rock that was on his foot
which would then move to the side and
slip loose and go back down okay so if
he had had a bit of bigger jack this
might have worked so he's also in a
super awkward position because just
there's no room so it's causing him
tremendous pain in his abdominals his
back his neck his wrist is you can bring
that up down there and this forum no boy
my back is so sore
really yeah it's just well this I mean I
understand yeah yeah arm to God you know
what hurts on me oh I'm just saying oh
every all the whole thing I'm gonna get
what is your [ __ ] back hurt I'm in a
massage tonight I have to I have had the
shits in st. those nineteen sausage
sandwiches oh by the way you set a
record most sausage is eaten in a cave
yeah yeah there's a certificate waiting
20 hours so this goes on I mean for a
while he tries again The Rock lurches
Floyd yells keep turning fella it's
coming off with each turn the stone
shifts and falls and it goes back on his
foot he tries again and again again he
moves around he tries different angles
he tries every little angle in the whole
[ __ ] space but what he really needed
was the third hand he didn't have one so
he finally collapses from exhaustion
Burt Burton was there quote we all felt
like sitting down right there and crying
it was awful I crazy to suggest wrapping
a rope around the guy skeet then
adjusted for its covers and put a light
bulb around his neck for warmth
sleep without pants and he left Skeets
hands were purple and bruised up above
the National Guard had arrived okay
right on time but Skeets Miller was now
a hero The Courier Journal wrote quote
Cave City that's the nearby city Cave
City is Skeets crazy in fact if Cave
City where a kingdom Skeets could be the
reigning monarch without the slaw
hint of revolt among his royal subjects
by the way King Skeets should be a
rapper yes how is that not King skate
what's up King Skeets in the house gates
whatever whenever he left his hotel room
tourists would swarm him an informal
bodyguard followed him around an
informal bodyguard it was just like okay
go thank you yeah that happened with the
Bundys write about it do it I'll be your
bodyguard now I'm done I'm made by
Buddha went to prison for being an idiot
Wow at the cave a new man took over
Henry Carmichael the general
superintendent of the Kentucky rock
asphalt company okay Henry was appalled
at the primitive rescue attempts at 2:30
a.m. on Wednesday Henry sent two men
down to assess stability okay guys are
going down to check everything out must
be nice for Floyd to meet some more
people now the opening of the cave was
now wider than ever because of that
human chain right so they had the big
[ __ ] human chain right who are
getting stuff out like to bring it out
the dirt like no they're all in suits
it's like you're gonna go dig holes and
guys like well I'll just wear my digging
suit yeah you got a dress up so as they
go deeper the cave actually gets tighter
normally Kentucky caves are very stable
and and are always 45 degrees okay sorry
54 degrees but this situation is
different because the human chain had
happened okay so they had all this
humans lying all the way up the top and
all the way back down which causes a
cave to get warmer okay so he's got a
hot cave so Skeets came up wait right so
Skeets came up with the idea for the
human chain which caused the cave
temperature to fluctuate from all the
bodies and all the camp fires up above
all things slow snow into the cave okay
so it's hot and it's wet wetter than it
should be water is pouring into the
tunnel large cracks start forming
remember karst topography it is the
limestone cave or dolomite or whatever
the ceiling starts to droop so now I'm a
cave one of the two volunteers sent down
they got super close they hear floyd
moaning as well as the rumble of sliding
rocks so that guy turns around he
doesn't go he doesn't go out but he goes
I'm getting out of this area yeah good I
mean yeah go get my butt the second
volunteer casey jones kept going and he
got to the 10-foot pit and he looked at
Floyd he tried to ignore that there were
pebbles falling around him don't worry
fight this is fine just rainy rocks my
friend Floyd begged KC to come down
quote can't now Floyd but I will when I
come back Floyd said quote I'm thirsty
of course you are yep I need water buddy
all right see it a bet
KC fell for it he slid first down into
the pit and handed Floyd some coffee
drink up buddy you thirsty
by the way you also want to be up as
much as possible what tea coffee tea
what do you want love a latte a vanilla
soy I hate to be that guy caramel
macchiato
boy didn't want the coffee KC realized
Floyd wasn't thirsty he just didn't want
to be alone he was thirsty
in a way KC's partner yelled the guy the
first guy yeah the guy's a smart guy
let's call him smart yeah he says we
need to get the [ __ ] out of here ok
smart guy earning the name KC put down
the ladle and scrambled out oh he's
lately coffee
here you go find as he looks back he saw
the passage closed like a vice no Floyd
still had the light bulb on his chest I
swear I am 4 a.m. on Wednesday February
4 I don't know that put something else
here
it's our 114 the walls clamp shut and
the K round Floyd went completely dark
his muffled sobs could be heard behind
the rocks
yes the [ __ ] worst
yeah well plus with those tears he'll be
loosening some of the rocks and he's
crying stay with me oh please don't
leave please don't leave oh boy
all right we gotta get out of here all
right so they go up the morning
Skeets arrives with the torch the plan
is to burn away the rocks that block the
way burn away the rocks so these are
soluble rah like the I don't know if
it's possible to burn limestone but I'm
probably is might take a long [ __ ]
time sure but remember water can
dissolve these rocks there's yeah that
makes sense but I mean it takes a while
it's just a tick to be like we're gonna
burn you out of here well it's probably
imagined I imagine he had looked it up
and I would imagine limestone rocks or
dolomite or whatever can be burned if it
worked the jacking would be easy but he
was told the cave it closed shut he
couldn't believe it and he went down
himself to see it was blocked
[Music]
it's weird I went down there and I heard
the caves crying the cave
the rocks are crying so weird
ah so weird I'm gonna stay right here
and drink some coffee and listen all
right sure Brock's um so he comes back
out that when he comes out as known as
nose is bleeding he's been down there
and I was a jar of time Skeets tells
Burton quote for God's sakes do not go
back down there and see that Homer
Collins doesn't go in again so Skeets is
giving up he's like this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
there's nothing that's gonna happen boy
but the person they needed to stop from
going down was Floyd's childhood friend
Johnny and Johnny was pissed he had said
all along not to put any people into the
cave because it would hate the cave and
cause it to change and collapse okay and
no one listened so Skeets idea
Skeets the hero had actually hurt the
situation caused it to be a [ __ ]
disaster
so Johnny got a group together that
evening quote there's death down there
the walls and ceiling are crumbling
unless you are determined to take the
biggest chance you ever took in your
life tell me now and stay outside that
Alex Jones quote yeah that's the same
speech that they did in Glengarry again
Ross without a father so he's saying
this is a death row yeah so some guys
volunteer over the next eight hours
Johnny would enter and leave the cave
five times at least five times maybe
more what's he doing down there
so he's sawing and chopping trees up top
showing up the cave walls again
underground a crew was reinforcing
cracks and wobbling boulders and
removing rocks
okay so sort of preventive movement and
then taking out the ones they needed to
get out of the way right when they could
hear each other
Johnny and giant old Floyd there had
been a breakdown and Floyd just started
to cry okay seems like flow he's not
handling this too well well they always
say that after five days in a cave you
start to go a little batty yeah I got
that Thanks no I don't want anything I
didn't get it I got it I know bats live
in caves sure it's you know it's a good
yeah
[Music]
so Johnny surgically tried to remove the
rocks in a few hours he can see light
from the bowl around Floyd's neck so
he's cutting through the rocks happening
then Johnny could squeeze through so
Johnny went to the service to get
equipment and said Floyd would be up in
an hour
wow that's quite a claim like I'm taking
him out and I get him out they didn't
now but a hundred and thirty two hours
Christ ah 10:30 p.m. at 10:30 p.m. on
Friday February 4th Johnny went in he
squeezed and crawled he plan to use a
grease gun to coat the rocks around
Floyd's leg to get him out so he had a
[ __ ] plan sure squeeze it squeeze it
grease it slide it out yeah it's a
three-step process - it was later you
can do with Floyd wait but when they got
to the cave there was no light shining
through the ceiling had collapsed once
again Johnny Alpher Floyd a big rock
fell and hit him on the head hit Johnny
on the head okay Johnny heard a moan and
quote I've done gone home and gone to
bed Oh Floyd was losing consciousness
yeah Johnny started to clear the passage
ignoring the pain from his head he
clawed at the stones then a sharp heavy
rock fell and hit him squarely on his
back 15 minutes later Johnny came out
and looked at the men quote I would not
go back in that during place if they
deed me the state of Kentucky well funny
you should say that you have driven a
bargain I cannot say no to the man with
the sash I'm the man with the mayor sash
have you noticed I have this hat and
draw the paperwork up big toe black hat
so but Johnny really is like the guy who
gives you hope johnny is the [ __ ]
hero he's the light at the end of the
tunnel that is correct I wish had a
picture Johnny I couldn't find one
though so or something no okay so so now
lieutenant-general HH den heart of the
national guard said they were going to
dig a shaft straight down to get him
okay so now they [ __ ] the cave right so
they're they're going over to where he
is which looks like it's like 60 70 feet
maybe and then they're gonna dig
straight down because because you can't
see this but basically floyd is called
floyd has crawled into a hole and then
damn and then sideways and he's 60 feet
deep so his plan is to dig 60 feet down
straight to him like basically build a
well and pull him out yeah he's gonna
dig a hole okay pull him out manholes
what are you gonna do I'd rather it be a
functioning water holder it's gonna be a
manhole bro there's coffee in this well
so now the state has assumed control of
the dick states take another no myrna's
private business den heart told Homer it
would take quote men with brains to get
Floyd out that's why he was in charge
yeah you know what you guys need
you guys need an [ __ ] yeah I mean
seriously yeah that's right yeah I'm the
FBI agent in die hard tack where the
president henry carmichael was told to
lead the dick volunteers from the
Louisville and Nashville railroad to the
southern signal company in the u.s.
mines rescue team and the engineers from
the State Highway Commission pitched in
the local townspeople were told to sit
this one out but we were down you dumb
locals we was fancy and a mob the brains
here why do you think I wear this big
hat a lot of brain he is smart he's had
Sheree's would that be stupid if I was
in charge in the National Guard
well I don't think in this country
anybody who's idiotic will rise to the
top of any situation that's right that's
it oh you must be smaller put your [ __ ]
down you dumb local [ __ ] I like
the way he talks to us his rhetoric is
something I respond to so this caused
resentment amongst the townspeople a
geology professor came and explained
that the best place to dig where the
best place to dig was but the locals
said he was wrong yeah shut him down and
they complain to the officials yeah they
said digging a shaft would take way too
long even Skeets who had once been full
of optimism was now completely full of
despair test soon proved what the locals
knew that the fancy heavy machinery they
want to use could not be used because
the cave basically inhale
exhaust gas power engine just gonna die
so it would just suck the fumes in and
kill Floyd so they realized that and
they realized they would have to dig the
55 foot shaft with picks and shovels
that's I mean but also fun bonding and
just takes a little longer couple more
minutes maybe our 146 oh god what I mean
he Thursday he went down on Friday I
don't know what he's gonna tell us boss
oh yeah I know he's not gonna buy that
I'm sorry you were we're in a cave and I
got why don't you say that to my face
again you mean you were in a cave yeah
you know what you're demoted you're on
the grill ah you're on the hill no I
don't need this [ __ ] I went down a cave
I've been in a hole for five days [ __ ]
you Floyd I'm not a [ __ ] business I'm
running I know
sorry king of burgers [ __ ] hole liar
Harry Harry Henry Carmichael estimate it
would take 30 hours to dig the shaft
well he's got it
Floyd's got the time yep had to clear
the docket by the evening the bet the
men started to slow down on the digging
that at 10 feet the chef narrowed so
only two men could get down there and
work at a time at 15 feet the shovels
hit boulders they started using pulleys
and buckets mules to pull the rocks out
the Sun set and rose it was an unusually
warm Friday all right now it's been a
week it's Friday
yeah your your dude in a [ __ ] hole
they put tarps up over the things rain
yeah it finally looks like the circus
that it is so the pace slows down
obviously groundwater is now seeping
into the shaft which we know is good
we've learned from earlier that you want
as much water going into this situation
water the nightmare but the groundwater
is making the walls crumble when they
dig so they're right yeah it's a [ __ ]
show the pace of digging is now down to
six inches per hour
okay so sting does at the 30 at the 30
hour timetable that they did Henry put
down uh-huh
they're just 17 feet in not 55 sure okay
that's lower yet if you know you were in
math but that's less not good but I'm
able to figure out that that is less
than problems yeah
Floyd's father Lee was up top pacing
lieutenant burden was worried Floyd
would die of hypothermia and got
permission to use a 75 foot hose to
blast me where I was who suggest earlier
this dude might pull a hose out of his
ass what warm air into the cave yes good
I don't know about warm air what do we
know what a Johnny say about warming up
the game we don't want to warm up the
case that's what Johnny said yeah so
this [ __ ] [ __ ] wants to blow warm
air into the cave to heat up Floyd right
yeah if in the moment makes sense
Johnny loses his [ __ ] [ __ ] and he and
he he starts screaming at Henri Carmical
you're a murderer for allowing burden to
do this they're gonna do it yeah oh my
god Johnny's the only one who's saying
no so the general Lieutenant General
their heart has Johnny banned and
dragged off by the national [ __ ] now now
the one guy I knew what the [ __ ] was
going on now - like like the movie
version you'd expect the only guy who
knows has been dragged off yeah so now
locals are furious they start talking
about getting their guns and driving the
National Guard off oh my god
any updates they've got really
pear-shaped man how long were you gone
you were gone for three hours it's all
[ __ ] how close y'all to get me out but
it's so it's so the [ __ ] stereotype
die hard
[ __ ] yeah this is an FBI situation now
gentlemen and what was the thing when he
says we're not gonna be able to get in
there I give you the FBI yes just the
[ __ ] idiot yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah so Floyd's been down there for 215
hours when Johnny came to town he found
Clara's cogging clogs so Johnny goes
back to town there's cars everywhere
okay can I get any more people are
pouring in from all over the [ __ ]
country
to check out the guy in the cave sure
reporter Nagrand oj photographers sketch
artist telegraph operators art is like a
dam but the photographers are here
that's not good for our business
telegraph operators radio operators and
other media people storm the cave cave
city skeets reporting had been in over
1200 newspapers across the country
making this a huge story silent film
crews show up to capture footage live
radio reports are being broadcast from
the cave sites this is one of the first
ever like live nasiha yeah media friends
it's one of the first big meeting so up
to this you would wait for the paper
you'd be like what's going on with that
cave guy and you'd read the story ninety
bag I can't wait to see in the morning
and you read about the guy in the
morning this is the first time ever
people could sit on the line right and
listen to this [ __ ] so it's all
everyone's just [ __ ] gripped radio
caused people to flood in at least
10,000 people come to cave City Cave
City has a population of population of
690 there's no 10,000 people there sure
it's like a [ __ ] Woodstock ten times
thirty right okay traffic packed the
road from the town to the cave pastures
were turned into mud parking lots
restaurants ran out of food homes were
turned into temporary hotels
accommodations were so limited that
visitors paid to nap in bathtubs not
asleep overnight just nap it's a tough
nap although when you think about Floyd
so it's like a carnival this is now the
site oh wow
hamburgers hamburgers it vendors sold
hot dogs hamburgers and knickknacks
families had picnics on the grass snake
oil salesmen came and sold miracle
potions of moonshiners or local
moonshiners were selling their White
Lightning religious groups came and sang
hymns and said prayers and as a referent
welcome to Floyd fast
Floyd fast for unbelievable days
jam-packed with
everything you need at Floyd Boy fast a
juggler showed up blue balloons were
sold to children with the word San Cave
printed on the side a nice memento to
celebrate that man chanting bones of a
man below come on so meet the slow death
of a human come out and celebrate the
chess collapse ain't enough Floyd a
barbed wire fence was put up around the
new rescue area to push everybody back
mm excited people watched outside the
wire Oh hardly anyone had come to help
it all just come to watch sure they came
to see Floyd pulled from the cave dead
or alive awesome good group fun but that
night the atmosphere died down they were
losing faith they would see anything no
I mean they drove all the way oh hey sir
you buy the whole can I say something no
boo this is the worst whole show I have
ever been to
Hardin it's the worst whole show I've
ever been to I've never seen worse whole
shows I've seen so many holes all right
who is stop talking to those people my
wife was a whole show sir get down get
down get down I'm going back to the
brothel go there god damn it my son Katy
puts on a baseball
oh my god frogs he uses frog any of the
police want to talk to this man
just putting frogs in his son I don't do
that Timmy does that on his own it's his
show okay come on so the tourists leave
they're all upset and I think it's
[ __ ]
it's not what their price I want my
money back you didn't pay to come here
oh the job out of town honking while men
dug another's paste at the site worried
about their friend and family member
drizzle came starts raining
I thought drizzle was gonna be a guy
Sergeant drizzle mud who's down the big
walls generators pumped out water on
Sunday the shaft was 25 feet down
halfway to the goal okay super slow
going not we're promised at all
no no they tried dynamite but I barely
chipped the boulders Jesus Christ he's
got to be down there like plays some
hammer I'll held held on their still
they still of high hopes the volunteers
came to relieve those who who were too
tired the Brotherhood of hobos sent aid
Wow yeah someone connected a radio
amplifier to the wire of Floyd's
lightbulb now you can hear about a [ __ ]
jar so what this would do is it would
detect vibrations when Floyd move so it
crackled 20 times a minute and they
realized this was because he was
breathing okay so they have a baby
monitor yeah they've made a baby monitor
basically okay so they got this crackle
they know he's okay but progress is slow
Tuesday comes Tuesday a week and we
consumption we can have we're being
technical yeah on Wednesday February
11th our 288 man the rain turned to snow
what that I mean come on the mud froze
okay Floyd's light went out in many ways
the shap was at forty four feet oh my
god this really is I mean this is a race
against time yeah Floyd's dad Lee asked
for donations from people and then
conspiracy theorists jumped in they
flick claimed Floyd was not even trapped
this was all about money oh wow you
gotta have them it's [ __ ] America is
this gotta have his queue behind this
the family newspapers railroads and Cave
City were all cashing in they said these
newspapers ran out of things to report
is the cave dummy it had become a
stagnant story so they started just
don't look at that they started just
preaching about they're not preaching it
just reporting about the conspiracy
theories right because there's nothing
else to tell it's a guy in a holes yeah
there's six feet away from proof which
is the title of the story yeah some
people sent telegrams to Floyd one came
from Kansas quote so from Floyd
Oh from Floyd yeah there it's people
trying to make it seem like it's a
conspiracy theories true Oh quote please
contradict statements that I am buried
alive in San Cave tell mother I'm
alright coming home Floyd Collins I just
there are so many similarities at times
thank knows another rumor was that the
Collins family loving publicity
deliberately delayed Floyd's rescue yeah
he just wanted to eat sausage down some
said Johnny had stopped rescuers from
entering the cave because he worked in
real estate and had a financial interest
in Crystal Cave absolutely yeah yeah who
doesn't want to buy the cave where a guy
died it meant that if no the other cave
the cave they own oh right oh right
johnny has a piece so Floyd dies he's
gonna benefit by getting his that
probably a resentful
also popularity double-a resentful John
Burton said Johnny
Gerald was quote guilty of nothing short
of murder when Johnny's the only
[ __ ] who did anything keep
digging
stop arguing the governor told general
den Hart to convene a military court of
inquiry to look into the conspiracy
theories so for a week military brass
interrogated rescuers and witnesses
Homer Collins Keats Miller Johnny Gerald
Robert Burton Homer just everybody the
inquiry concluded Johnny did reject help
but so at burdened Carmichael dint heart
everybody everybody was fighting each
rescue team believed competing rescuers
were incompetent which was pretty much
true they had little knowledge of caves
or they had no organizational skills but
no one had both okay Valentine's Day
came in calibrate for 36 hours okay I
mean he was down there I don't know it's
303 in 60 hours oh my god but he's been
down while he was down there they have
held in Marbury inquiry right yeah and
finished it and wrapped it up right and
there's six feet away boys tell me
what's going on with that military
enquiry about three weeks out Floyd the
court concluded no foul play had been
involved great dig just incompetence dig
55d deep fifty five feet of dirt and not
excavated okay Carmichael said to dig
sideways right because they've gone out
55 feet they must have missed missed a
shot right okay
Floyd had been trapped for 17 days 411
hours he's fine he's fine
wait 17 is 41 out having 111 hours I
could do this standing up I don't think
he could twelve without food but he
probably had water free water this
leaking member there's water yeah yeah
that's water he hasn't any food for 12
days yeah it's not burning any calories
either so no reporters were packed
outside the barbed wire fence two dozen
telegraph operators stood by seven
airplanes were in pastures waiting to
transport photographic negatives to
faraway newsrooms Wow
seven right it's good good resource
management at 1:30 p.m. on Monday
February 16th a chisel penetrated to
sand cave they frantically widened the
hole and a rescuer flashed his light in
they had broken through the 10-foot pit
the man eased into the cave and aimed
his flashlight at Floyd crickets
scattered so he's fightin crickets ok
good protein the man saw a glimmer
it was Floyd's gold tooth which was not
moving at all
the man said shook his head and yelled
quote dead anywho what let's get out of
here that's a good hold digging boys
another guy okay we're a team now we're
not breaking this up we got him there
he's dead I said to him it yeah we were
you thinking I mean he's they really
hung in there you did hang in there
impressive as [ __ ] yeah it's a good
thing they had that military meeting
that's right dammit
Floyd have been dead for three days he
died just after the lightbulb just after
the lightbulb went out officials decided
to me to keep Floyd entombed where he
was thinking if they tried to take the
body out it'd be too dangerous for the
men okay so on Tuesday February 17th
motion picture cameras film the Collins
family as they say goodbye to Floyd
a choir saying soil was putting the
shaft they just were like berry no we
got to do is fill this one yeah he's in
a grave yeah
the Collins family it was poor as ever
locals saw Floyd's dad scouring the
rescue site for glass bottles then the
owner of the San Cave be Doyle put up a
sign on the highway 200 yards away the
body of Floyd Collins is imprisoned in
San Cave
oh no no 50 cents 9news one could look
at the whole that 8 Floyd Collins a man
be Boyle had once called the friend he's
now making money off in capital isn't
good though it is good just makes gives
you heart it does it's warms the soul
and paths do it
some rescuers got vaudeville contracts
and toured theaters what it's like when
like YouTube stars get TV shows it it
was this was when you would get a
contract and just you would go and tell
the story of what happened yeah he'll
come and listen and you tell a story
right it's pretty entertaining damn what
else
Skeets Miller was offered 50,000 from a
lecture circuit he turned it down and
went back to reporting for the
Louisville courier-journal Homer Collins
toured vaudeville stages for eight
months but he was just trying to save
money to get Floyd out of that hole
quote I kept thinking of Floyd lying in
the muck where he had suffered beyond
our power to imagine I would never have
peace of mind if he remained there after
he was able to get enough money he hired
miners on April 17th and they read ugh
the shaft and removed the rock pinning
Floyd's leg two months after he is that
time oh yeah
it weights 27 pounds no it's three
months three months after February March
you're right
whatever yeah I'm good I'm good I don't
you I do number you think human do you
do you do you do months I leave numbers
that's exactly right
on April 26 1925 Floyd Collins was put
in a grave in the family cemetery a
stalagmite might hit you up the ass
that's right yeah
headstone marked his plot that's nice
yeah nice touch things have gotten worse
since the accident people were actually
avoiding the area now because of Floyd's
accident and death avoiding like walking
near I guess they just thought it was
cursed or something but people were just
not trying to cave city anymore
more and more cave explorers started
trying to find the next big cave and
losing their lives in underground some
more people were dead
yeah man people are poor they're trying
to [ __ ] make money and in this area
what are they gonna do find a [ __ ]
cave strike it rich
we'll be back there yeah the federal
government was aware this was becoming a
problem Lee Collins Floyd's dad sold his
stake in Crystal Cave okay that wasn't
all he sold no god damn it no what why
it's your child
he agreed allowed dr. Henry Thomas a
dentist to exhume a display for Floyd
body a dentist in a glass cupboard
coffin inside crystal cave man
oh that's what yeah I got $10,000 see
that down there yeah so that's where
you'd go and check him out yeah the
horrified Collins family you know I give
you permission when I go yeah you're
allowed to put me on display and make
money off I love that all right I love
that thing you can say I appreciate that
man actually I want to be in the body
farm
the horrified Collins family obviously
wanted to stop people from looking at
the embalmed body of quote but the daddy
said you did it great escape the dad
wanted yeah but the rest of the family
was like that seems rude yeah
insensitive
[Music]
Congress authorized turning Mammoth Cave
into a national park in 1941 one reason
was so the government could control who
went underground because all these guys
are going down there and dying right so
they're buying it up piece by piece but
they bought the big piece and then they
slowly went bought all the little caves
so they're buying a caves around the
area
so I need to own the land obviously it's
buying up in 1961 the government bought
Crystal Cave for two hundred and eighty
five thousand dollars okay
Floyd was still inside Floyd was oh god
oh my god oh god in 1961 there is
eventually public access to the cave was
closed off in 1989 Floyd's body was
buried in a Baptist cemetery oh right on
time Jesus Christ man
professional covers eventually cavers
professional cameras eventually
confirmed Floyd's hunch the caves in the
region are all connected 405 miles of
passageways the mammoth cave system is
now the world's longest but one cave is
isolated sand cave is still separate in
the 80s the cave interest was
permanently sealed with a steel gate
bolted and welded shut
to this day cavers continued to explore
the 405 plus mile mammoth system and
find the letters F C scratched into the
rocks wow that's crazy yeah
Jesus what that is where the phrase get
her done came from that's what where the
phrase get her done came from right wow
what a what a little ride how do you
feel about yourself good good that I
should not complain on planes anymore do
you feel like America is better or worse
than it was I think America is better
than it was but in a race to be worse
yes that is correct
we are the winners losers of all winner
and loser town know where they yeah
we're the winners who are like we'd
never lose just the fact we're the bad
guy in an 80s movie I can't a man just
died like can't a man just just have a
problem and die and
have that well you know like even when
you talk about something like that like
today right
we wouldn't people wouldn't come there
and sell hamburgers and stuff but it
would be exploited in the other ways
where the news would be there with the
breaking news logo up the whole time
what's the difference between the barbed
wire and the two thousand people around
it and selling hamburgers and watching
on CNN yeah it's the sensation selling
ads for sure it's all the same you're
making money off of a guy's suffering
news is making money off of suffering
and that's that that is the thing that
we love now more than anything is like
capitalism and the news don't work
because you do not get the news if there
is profit incentive you know what I was
thinking you get something else you get
hysteria you get nonsense but if it's
not profit eyes if they can legally not
get ratings the news is the new yes the
news is a huge problem and what I was
thinking the other day is like what you
really need is we need somebody who is
like like in charge of ordering our
problems in charge of like just someone
who's just like yeah I understand how
upsetting that is but you know we need
to save earth in order to solve
Palestine you know but then what I
realized was we did have that it was the
person who was the news anchor that
person was like here are the six [ __ ]
things that are terrible here's what's
going that's how you knew what mattered
crunket Cronkite would de Voort devote
an entire 30 minutes to one subject yeah
or and like dan Rather there you know
like a lot over the years it was like
you had this kind of one or two people
who would be like telling you what was
important and yeah like you're saying
like Cronkite would be like okay you
know the the Vietnam is such a huge
story that's what we're going to talk
about instead but now because there's so
many voices it is the it's that is the
by reporting on the president's tweets
if everyone in the media who felt like
they were fed up of the behavior and
like the treatment of the press and
stuff we're just like we will no longer
report the tweets yeah if they all agree
to do that what a huge leg that takes
out is the way that the
people communicate there's stories about
people taking all their scooters in
Santa Monica lectric scooters that are
put everywhere yeah people getting mad
that they're on lawns and stuff and so
there's all these stories of people
throwing them in the water and setting
them on fire and doing other stuff but I
think that if they do that they should
be made to watch a five-minute video of
the fires in Northern California and the
people dying from heat yeah all over the
world and just have to watch that and go
are you sure are you sure the scooters
the problem we need a lot to get
clockwork orange'
[ __ ] yes like we need to set up like
open like United everything work Orange
people's gotta start Clockwork Orange
how is that not a thing and here's how
you do it you just set it up anywhere
where there's those things where it's
like put your business card in to win a
cruise yeah anybody throws their
business card in there right there all
clockwork you're absolutely right after
that yeah by the way there's some people
listed right now who are like how the
hell did they make a guy getting trapped
in a cave about Trump Oh
everything's about Trump hey sorry I'm
sorry if you think that that we're being
wrong and and tying their everything
into Trump but guess what shit's [ __ ]
deal with it yeah honestly well you know
big boy a lot of times like when you're
dealing with you know like a movement
that is leading you towards fascism you
have two options you can either tie a
rope around it and try to drag it out
yeah or just take the shoe off take the
shoe off and race it up I think it'd be
better to just take the shoe off
just don't let everybody in the cave yes
the worst thing and what we're doing
right now is we're the people on land
arguing about how to get Floyd out of
the cave while he dies that's right yeah
all right everybody ready Jim fun are
you freaked out about the cave story it
is quite literally my worst nightmare
by the way I think it's Ticketmaster
that refuses to put up our picture
because the guy thinks that it's
offensive
I think it's Ticketmaster oh yeah well
like a head guy Ticketmaster thinks it's
offensive grow some balls to get master
your offensive yeah your existence
alright alright buying cars okay